subi vraiment des attaques frontales
injuste et en deux mois que monsieur
mais cela était réélu il nous enlève
tout d'un coup comme ça alors que une
autre est de privilégier ce qui est faux
gv atteindre jusqu'à 1400 balle je
travaille dur tous les jours j'ai aucun
avantage là par la piscine et la
patinoire gratuite il nous enlève notre
cause les comité des oeuvres sociales ni
nous ans il veut nous enlever cinq jours
de congés la médaille on a plus de jour
on a plus de chèque il faut la payer si
on veut la voir
il veut nous enlever nos ponts ils
veulent nous enlève tout sens ghosn a en
fait voilà frontalement le recul d'hier
et edu partout et qu'il s'est quand même
augmenté de 270 % et que nuit veut nous
faire travailler plus pour gagner moins
c'est intolérable
on n'est pas des privilégiés dans la
fonction voilà c'est la colère et psion
est écrit un rapport de force pour pas
laisser faire tout ce qu'il veut faire
ils pensent privatiser service des eaux
il pense enfin voila il a pas encore de
dossiers dans sa casquette là et on va
on va prendre cher il est il participe à
la casse du service public de sa propre
ville il maltraite ses propres agents
c'est intolérable insupportable fm en
colère et on lâchera rien
[Musique]